week eight began on thursday night it
continues early sunday 9 30 a.m eastern
the final england game of the year and i
like breaking out any of the games from
one o'clock i don't care where you put
them sunday morning saturday night
wherever they fit i like being able to
watch one game instead of trying to
watch nine or ten at once and it's
equals jaguars it feels like an
elimination game stats and i think the
team that loses this one is going to be
in very big trouble are you willing to
say that the loser of this game is out
of the playoffs entirely
no no because i think the eagles could
lose and still win the division now
they're going to have to worry about
washington gaining separation but i
think the eagles can still win the
division they've got five games left
within the division and i think the
jaguars as well could pull their way
back into it so i don't think the
loser's done but boy the loser is going
to be in a very deep hole with five
losses with eight games to play
will you go breakfast beer since the
game kicks off at 9 30.
now i work on sunday
some of us work on sunday i can't sit at
home in my pjs my onesie pjs like you do
your 49ers onesie pjs eating wings and
drinking beer sorry no i i have to work
you wish you could all right let's go
ravens at panthers what's more likely
mike another multiple score comeback by
cam newton or another shutout by the
ravens
you know you love this what's more
likely thing though what i i don't like
this what's more likely because reality
is typically in the middle i don't think
there's going to need to be a comeback
in this one i like the panthers at home
there's questions about cam newton's
health ron rivera the coach of the
panthers says he will be fine and he'll
play he hasn't thrown yet this week
because of a lingering shoulder issue
but i think the panthers at home
motivated by being the underdogs and
also i think galvanized remember doug
peterson said the eagles were galvanized
by blowing that lead i don't think he
know what knows what galvanized means
you become galvanized when you overcome
the 17 point deficit which is what the
panthers did and i think that will carry
over into this week and and the ravens
are going to be searching for some
answers after they fall to 4-4
the bengals gave up 550 yards to the
chiefs last week my good news they're
welcoming the bucks who actually put up
the most yards per week in the league
yeah but i think there's a fundamental
difference between the buccaneers and
the chiefs the buccaneer is not as
explosive as they were early this year
and i i think the bengals you know the
players only meeting does that ever work
i don't know but i think at home against
a buccaneers team where the bengals feel
the urgency and they want to atone for
what happened last week you know on to
cincinnati has always been that mantra
after you have an embarrassing loss and
you have to turn it around and win they
can't say on to cincinnati other than
the fact they're going home to
cincinnati but i feel like it's going to
be that kind of game where the bengals
could win this one going away
russell wilson and the seahawks go to
detroit to face the lions mike the best
quarterback on the field and this one
will be
i still think it's russell wilson
because of the dual threat we haven't
seen as much of the running this year
and he hasn't lived up to the hype you
know it seems like every other year or
so an inordinate amount of hype emerges
about russell wilson once people
appreciate what he did the year before
but he's very steady he's very effective
he's the centerpiece of that team now i
think a lot of the changes have been
made there are all about building the
team around russell wilson and and i
think with extra time to get ready with
the motivation that will come from
trying to honor the memory of paul allen
who owned that team for more than 20
years i know that the seahawks aren't
favored to win the three-point underdogs
i like the seahawks to go to detroit and
win this game outright and and maybe
propel a wild card run i'm i i never
give up on any of my preseason
predictions until they're mathematically
impossible although i am willing to
concede the seahawks winning the nfc
west unlikely at this point i think they
could still propel themselves into the
wild card mix and who knows maybe get
round three against the rams in january
the giants are already preparing for
next year but they still have to play a
game mike they welcome in washington are
we gonna see big blue just mail it in
this is the time of year where you have
to wonder whether or not there's going
to be the major league dynamic right
wasn't that the movie where the baseball
team deliberately tries to stink and the
players become galvanized there's that
word again i i wonder how the players
react to the trade of eli apple the
trade of damon harrison i don't know
that the absence of those two guys
really affects the defense given the way
it's currently constituted
does that provide the
the wake-up call to the rest of the team
will there be a desire after what
happened monday night to get that bad
taste out of their mouths about all the
criticism they took for lollygagging the
last few minutes of the game i don't
know this one goes either way because
we're talking about a washington team
that we continue to underestimate
they've now won two in a row they're
four and two and i i
this one could easily go either way i
mean that's really going out on a limb
yes it could go either way it will go
either way but i really can't get a good
beat on this one because i just don't
know how the giants are going to react
to what's going on this week denver goes
to kansas city last time they played
mike the broncos held the chiefs to
their lowest scoring output of the
season can they do it again
yeah that's a little bit deceptive
though because it was in that final
seven minutes that the chiefs pulled off
a couple of touchdowns and ultimately
won the game i think the chiefs are
going to continue to roll they are
sliding into that dominance phase of the
season where the teams that they should
beat they will beat and they will beat
convincingly jets and bears very quietly
mitchell trubisky 11 touchdowns just
three picks his last three games yeah
you know what the jets even though they
lost by 20 last week to the vikings they
looked pretty good and and i could see
the jets keeping this one close
the bears
they need to be
feeling good about where they are six
games in even though you can look and
say well maybe they should be four and
two maybe they should be five and one i
think in august you tell the bears fan
they're gonna be three and three they'll
be very happy with that so we'll see if
they can win the next two and get to
five and three they've got the jets and
the bills but it's not going to be easy
on sunday against the jets
all right let's continue with the sunday
games for week 8 of the 2018 nfl regular
season stats where did we leave off well
we got to finish one early game brown
steelers they tied in week one mike the
browns win this game if
if they score more points than
pittsburgh oh right
i mean that's that is a corrupt you know
i used to hate questions like that i
remember being in high school and every
once in a while that's why i don't like
fill in the blank you you could be
i and and really
stats you may be surprised to notice i
was always inclined to be a bit of a
smart ass
that that fill in the blank there's a
lot of possibilities there's a lot of
possibilities they say there's only one
right answer oh i beg to differ there
are plenty of right if you give me a
blank spot i can come up with a lot of
potential answers unfortunately not the
ones that get you the grade that you may
be looking for look the browns need to i
don't know i don't know i don't know
what they need to do here i mean the
steelers have have the bye week the
steelers are starting to click james
connor is good and ben roethlisberger is
healthy and antonio brown's getting it
done now juju smith schuster is a great
compliment i i don't look that i i
admire the browns for what they've done
so far this season they had that game
against the chargers it was the first
time they were really beaten every other
game's been close i like the fact that
they came back against the bucks i just
don't think going to pittsburgh
i'll be very impressed with baker
mayfield and i already am but my my
estimation of him will be
adjusted dramatically if he ends up
winning this game i don't think he will
i just don't think it's going to happen
i just think that right now there's that
sense that the browns are wobbly a
little bit
the the hugh jackson comments about the
offense and you know todd haley trying
to smooth it all over i just think that
that provides a a backdrop for the
browns that does not make it conducive
to beating the steelers
packers go to la to take on the rams
mike what's more likely aaron rodgers
struggling against wade phillips or
rogers just lights it up in a shootout
given that aaron rodgers passed for 77
yards the last time he faced a wade
phillips defense i'd say it's more
likely that he struggles especially
because he doesn't have the weapons
around him he doesn't have the tools
around him on both sides of the ball and
here's the thing
if the rams i mean you don't have to
stop the packers many times if you can
shred them defensively and score score
score it's 21 to seven before you know
it how do you dig out of that hole if
you can't you know okay hey we got a
field goal in that drive all right the
rams scored another touchdown hey we
scored a touchdown yeah so did the rams
oh we had to pump while the rams scored
a touchdown the next thing you know it's
42 to 15. i i just i look
i don't know if the packers can keep
this close or not i i think that this is
the beginning of a difficult stretch for
the green bay packers they go on the
road four out of five times and i have a
feeling this day is not going to go well
for aaron rodgers and company and this
may be a game that we come back to and
look at if it's an embarrassment for the
team this may be one of those games that
greases the skids toward coaching change
drew brees and kirk cousins on sunday
night football mike i put the over under
on touchdown passes for this game at
five and a half where are you going i
always i always like it when you go half
because i don't like a push on these
i'll go over i i think though i think
that it's going to be you know not quite
45 42 but i could see 34 31 30 to 27. i
could see an exciting not ridiculously
high scoring game but a very competitive
game featuring some great plays on
offense some defensive stops when needed
and uh yeah i'll go let me let me take
the over that because especially since
yeah i'm rooting for a good game on
sunday night all right colts and raiders
if the colts win mike and get to three
and five do you consider them a real
contender in the afc south
well they're going to go back at that
and look at that texans game that they
lost and that's the one that's going to
hurt them down the stretch because even
if they win they're two full games and a
tiebreaker behind the texans um i'm not
ready to write them off and i think they
will win
but
the fact that the texans have emerged
the last couple of weeks will make it
harder for the colts to pull themselves
back into it game of the week 49ers in
arizona to take on the cardinals does
the loser of this game get the number
one overall draft pick oh no no you got
the raiders you got the giants and we
know that the raiders and the giants are
at least trying to lose because they're
trading off assets the cardinals and the
49ers aren't doing that so no i think
the loser of this game is going to be in
position for a top three but uh i it was
about 10 15 years ago that 49ers
cardinals was the worst that the nfl
could offer by way of an in division
rivalry and now here we are again one
win between them and the cardinals win
came against the 49ers i mean other than
when they play the 49ers the cardinals
are winless so
uh yeah i this is not must-see tv stats
will you still watch it oh yeah i'll be
locked in look i can't not it's a
sickness mike
i can't stop it
yeah and i don't know that there's any
cure for it if you're gonna watch this
one although i do think the 49ers will
win just because somebody has to i've
got no basis no analysis just yeah it's
two really bad teams and somebody's
gonna end up with more points and maybe
the 49. hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports